i i've been having such a blast on the
show i never want to get used to it you
know what i mean i really think that's
one of the secrets of life is if you
have something you love don't get used
to it i don't want to just saunter into
work just like oh what's up
another another video response from a
pop star
put it on the pile ho hum
ho hum i say
it's a thrill and that's one of the keys
to life never get used to the things you
love even the simple things like driving
that's right driving i'm going to
celebrate driving
it's simple but people are like oh it's
just a way to get from point a to point
b it's a pain who cares no
it's the best
it's the greatest it's 4 000 pounds of
steel and glass that you get to navigate
and they didn't exist 127 years ago i
looked that up
127 years ago no cars do you realize how
lucky you are to exist in the sliver of
humanity that gets to drive a car
before that what was a horse
you got a horse a thing with free will
an animal a beast that you have to feed
and shelter and at any moment could just
be like you know i don't feel like going
to the five and dime
horse a lot of ordinary things are
amazing even like going to the movies
people act like that's so drab like what
you do this weekend oh nothing
nothing much
if you laugh i will milk it out
you can feel him like if we i think he's
reacting
nothing much me and phillip
nope now now i'll reel it in
just the business what you do we just we
went and saw a movie we wouldn't just
saw a movie when saw just just went and
saw a movie you you jaded
is that it
it says you jaded on the card i did not
i did not write that and you could feel
a hesitance i was like you just oh you
jaded
hoot ninny i should have said who minnie
this is more of a hootin in the face
i'm just saying don't get used to going
to the movies they're amazing sure it's
expensive but think of all the great
stuff you get to do for 13.75 first of
all you get to see
a movie
a 300 million dollar blockbuster
that looks bigger than when they filmed
it it's it's bigger they stretched out
russell crowe jesus a huge wrestle
all in a place where it's not only
accepted but encouraged to pig out on
candy and popcorn and then just litter
it everywhere
like a mongolian king of old enjoying
his spoils like we fought a good fight
raise an x as is standard
movies are the best
how many places
how many places can you take a girl and
it's dark and you can just slowly reach
out your hand and hold her hand without
her being like dude you wear it out
in the movie it's totally fine because
it's dark it's soothing it's black and
white pitch black environment red velvet
cushion chair equipped with a movable
armrest has it pretty much just whispers
go ahead
finger her
never get used to it
you